home is just down the hill so close and
yet so far
they fought against myanmar's military
opposing its Coupe after getting
seriously injured they fled to Thailand
but they haven't accepted defeat we want
to inspire other injured comrades that
you don't have to lie in bed with
depression you can see us we still keep
walking no matter what people see that
we are moving forward regardless until
we succeed with the revolution
[Music]
now their Battlefield is YouTube their
weapons of choice a camera and some pots
and pans
they run a cooking channel using the
skills they learned in Jungle camps it's
a challenge with the injuries they
sustained
both lost limbs in the fighting
but they haven't let that stop them
injuries like theirs are increasingly
common these free Burma Rangers are
rushing to the cries of a colleague he
screams in pain after stepping on a
landmine while on patrolling Kaya State
last year they say the mines were
planted by myanmar's military after its
soldiers set fire to a nearby Church
the young man survived but lost his foot
this Clinic just over the Border in
Thailand is one of several treating
those who survive air attacks artillery
and heavy armor are inflicting wounds
that often result in lost limbs if not
death the open air Ward might seem basic
but inside Myanmar there's little Choice
patience told us that there are no
medical workers or doctors on the other
side there's no clinic or sufficient
medicine as well that's why they told me
that they have to come all the way here
for those people that get injured in the
fighting inside Myanmar getting across
to Thailand is a double-edged sword over
here they're safe and there's health
care but they're also stateless and they
have to live underneath the radar
back in the open air kitchen the food's
nearly ready fried fish in a chili sauce
and a vegetable curry
It's A Taste of Home
as close as they can get for the moment
as he wraps up door what dedicates the
show to those still fighting across the
border even though they can't be there
he says the revolution will succeed Tony
Chang Al Jazeera on the time Myanmar
border